[Music]
[Applause]
sam amick the senior nba writer
said sources uh the lakers head coach
frank bogle's job in serious jeopardy
despite the jazz win
they have a game tonight which i would
lead me to believe is frank vogel's job
still in jeopardy as they host the
pacers sam good morning
good morning dan thanks for having me
sir so is his job in jeopardy
it is for sure uh you know i
to me the human element dan is is like
always coming into play here the
emotions got really really high
after the denver loss which shouldn't
shock anybody
you know trailing by 45 at one point
losing by 37.
you know yes you don't have anthony
davis but the nuggets don't have jamal
murray they don't have michael ford jr
so that was as close as frank had come
to
losing his job and
you know i saw your segment earlier and
and your two cents on why they wouldn't
just fire him now and and you know you
kind of got me to make sure i had the
answer to that question ready for you
the truth is i don't think they have
the faith in the rest of their coaching
staff you know david fizdale is a former
head coach and the kind of guy who
certainly has the chops to do it um but
there is a sense that in the collective
in terms of the staff they don't
necessarily think that it would put them
in a better spot and to frank's credit i
know it's just one game but that utah
game was big because the mood was such
that if those players wanted to say
goodbye to him then all they had to do
was roll over and they obviously didn't
do that yeah but if they lose tonight at
home to the pacers or you know they go
on this road trip and they you know
no i hear you for sure i i it is going
to continue to be tenuous but the jazz
game specifically
the jazz game specifically is like you
have lebron
choosing in denver to not address the
media which is very unlebron like and
then he later explained that he didn't
want to say things that he would regret
which kind of tells you how everybody
was feeling from the front office to the
players to the owner everybody's upset
um and then lebron apologizes on twitter
which is not the kind of thing he
typically does obviously you have magic
out there tweeting so all those things
thrown together made the jazz win huge
but yeah like it's gonna continue to be
challenging um and we'll see where it
goes
okay if they had lost to utah on monday
night
was he gonna get fired
uh i think it was a very very strong
possibility depending on it sounds funny
about the optics yes wins and losses
matter if you lose by two and you play
well
and
still send the message i mean all
throughout that game it's funny a lot of
the lakers media corps and my colleague
bill aurum who i obviously authored this
story with and others were tweeting
about how the scary part for the lakers
in that game is that they were playing
really well but then they would fall
behind and you would start in real time
asking that question of you know how do
you separate playing well versus winning
and so i you know i don't know for sure
what would have happened after the utah
game but it was extremely touch and go
and if they had been blown out uh then i
think frank probably would have been out
but again you have all these layers to
it right you've got the fact that when
frank was in trouble before
and i'm talking earlier in the season
like we reported you know kurt rambas
who's an advisor with the lakers had
made it clear to that coaching staff
that they were in a bad spot
then frank gets covet then he's out for
five games you know to me one of the
interesting what-if scenarios is you
know david fizdale ends up going one and
four during that stretch and so it's a
small sample size but as ownership in
the front office looks at it and asks
the question of you know if if not this
guy then what are we doing that that
didn't paint a picture that it would be
rosier on the other side and i think
that kind of stuff is coming into play
too
what what is frank vogel not doing
that
is going to cost you mr he didn't build
the team
right no i'm with you i mean this is the
tricky part you know this you've been
doing it so long the tricky part of
being the messenger on these types of
stories is we're certainly not endorsing
the logic behind
firing frank you know what i'm saying
like we're relaying what's happening
internally but opinion wise i would 100
fall into your side frank is a high
level coach a guy who after winning a
championship i don't think deserved to
have to wait as long as he did for an
extension that was curious and i think
you know missing the mark on the lakers
part then when he got the extension as
we reported at the time they only gave
him an additional year so he's running
through 2022 2023 that was another sign
that the ground beneath him wasn't all
that stable
so we kind of knew this going in and it
then comes down to the old pro sports
adage of how you can't fire the players
you know i just covered this in my
backyard in sacramento luke walden gets
fired certainly he had made mistakes the
kings aren't any better for it you know
they promoted alvin gentry but it's when
the pressure
reaches a point at these different
organizations that you feel like just
something has to be done it's either the
coaching change or it's a big trade or a
gm loses his job in this case you know
that's not what's going to happen right
now
and trade deadline coming up quick so
maybe they can find a way to improve
around the edges and relieve pressure
elsewhere sam amick the senior nba
writer for the athletic if i gave the
lakers a do-over with russell westbrook
yeah i don't think they would do it and
i think in all my years of covering the
league one of the more unique if not you
know kind of a
case all its own situations regarding
the communication between
the star players the front office and
the machinations behind how this trade
came to be
are not conventional meaning that you
know as you know
and a lot of people know by now you know
russell westbrook had this strong desire
to come play for the lakers to come home
had made that clear had gone to lebron
james's house and met with lebron and
anthony davis and talked about this
vision you know the front office ends up
green lighting it they end up doing it
but
you know in doing so they
had a buddy healed trade with sacramento
that was on the brink of being done that
ended up getting derailed so whether
it's you know turning back time and
doing the buddy heel trade to give you
more shooting and just you know let
lebron and a.d
try to repeat what they did in 2020
i think they would do it over again
because
it's i think russ is an all-time great
he's an incredible player in the right
environment so do you think that they
would do this deal again with russ
no i'm sorry if i wasn't clear i don't
think they would do it i think they
would no i don't think they would do it
okay i think what they're learning the
hard way is and i'm i'm parroting the
scouts that i've talked to
about this is that rus the ceiling on
how much rust helps you is is fairly low
because you have lebron james on your
team that you know he's not helping you
off the ball and if lebron got hurt
russ you know knock on wood he doesn't
rust could be a savior for the lakers he
could be the kind of guy that keeps them
afloat you know and and wins them games
because then russ could be rust that's
what puzzled me so much about his desire
to make this move in the first place
then when he went from houston to
washington
the whole desire then was i'm tired of
sacrificing with james harden
and i want to go be russ again and
scotty brooks his old buddy from
oklahoma city was sitting there in the
nation's capital saying let's do it
let's go and they did it and guess what
for six months at the tail end of last
season the optics around russ were great
again because he was fantastic uh in
that environment he was very good player
and this one he just doesn't help them
that much
i can't help but wonder about the
supporting cast that they have now and
the supporting cast that they had when
lebron got there with ingram and lonzo
ball i mean i go back to julius randle
you can throw in kuzma in there uh
you know if you said to lebron hey
can i have a do-over here
we're we're full of do-overs here what
do you want to have those young kids
there with him now i know they rolled
the dice they got anthony davis they won
a championship
but right long term
who's going to help you win more
championships anthony davis or that
supporting cast that you got rid of
i i mean on that one i'm gonna say
lebron does exactly what they did now
would he love to have held on to one or
two more of those players yeah for sure
but a chip is a chip you know what i
mean and for him
you know to get that fourth one to do it
in a third market with a third team
gave him a you know another layer to his
legacy that nobody can ever take away
and you do get the sense
lebron is is challenging for me to even
cover because the guy works his tail off
you can't question the work ethic the
way he you know prepares his body and
competes
um and so he's still trying to play like
lebron but you do have a feeling like
he's gonna give it his best goal but
because he got a championship with the
lakers you know that this is a a
successful chapter in his career and
sure he would love to put another cherry
on top so i don't think he would trade
that that deal uh but for you know you
see lonzo balling out in chicago you
know brandon's become a very good player
in new orleans and kuzma doing his thing
in dc i mean those guys would help and
within all that you're talking about
losing alex caruso um prioritizing
taylon horton tucker you know who's not
having a very good year signing kendrick
nunn and this is just unfortunate but
you know he hasn't even hit the floor
yet because of injuries so the role
players as much as we talk about russ i
mean the role players might even be a
more relevant discussion with the lakers
is there a market trade market for ben
simmons
yes 100 um i'm somewhat surprised by
you know i wrote last week about some of
the concerns coming from
interested teams regarding you know not
only ben's
kind of the the uncertainty around where
his head is at where his game would be
at but even through all that there's a
ton of interest
and you know it's just a matter of
reading daryl mori's mind in philly and
trying to find out does he actually want
to get a deal done before the deadline
or
is he stalling to get to this summer you
know one of the growing
subplots if you will is you know his
desire to reunite with james harden
again and do a signing trade with
brooklyn potentially um you know where
does joella bead fit into all this and
so you know you got to be kind of a
psychologist to figure this thing out
right now but
but you know yeah there's a market um
you know arsham sharanya at the athletic
had had pegged sacramento portland
atlanta indiana minnesota as the five
leaders in that clubhouse could be
somebody else but uh yeah there's i
think a pretty robust market
do you think it gets done
right now i'm saying yes
now i'm a little bit you know hesitation
is that i'm guilty of listening to
a lot of the teams that want him you
know this admittedly this is not the
sixers quietly telling me yeah we got to
get something done like i haven't heard
that um
and the ben simmons people don't have
total clarity either no they're quick to
tell you
all right if they don't do a deal like
don't think ben's coming back you know i
don't think my prediction would be he's
he's not going to play for them this
season if he doesn't get traded so
that's where you got to reconcile
with the big fella you know joel embiid
made headlines the other day when he
talked about
the fact that he didn't think they had
urgency to make change right now um so
basically supported the front office and
their stance and kind of created the
appearance of patience on their side and
and that's where this stuff kind of gets
fun because the next few weeks we're
going to filter through all that and
figure out what was fact and what was
fiction
congrats on the story there sam thanks
for joining us as always we appreciate
it
you got it dan thanks man sam amick the
senior nba writer for the athletic